on the next episode of AMC's The Walking
Dead I know what the Savior's are and I
know what they do they cannot be trusted
what exactly are you asking
don't do something now things will go
bad
and when you do
we lose everything
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Walking
Dead mid-season finale trailer
negan has like blood all over his face
and he's shaved so it looks like he just
killed someone so we had so much to talk
about just a heads up - there is a new
round of the walking dead giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video make sure you click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss out on
anything so much happening it's another
90 minute episode but you basically have
all the different groups coming in to
play we've kind of been jumping around
this season so we have Kingdom's stuff
we have Savior stuff with Daryl then we
have the stuff back at the safe zone in
whatever it is that rake in Aaron find -
so there's so much to get through but
the big thing that stands out from this
trailer is the beardless negan comic
book negan so if you haven't read the
comics Nikken does not have a beard but
when Jeffrey Dean Morgan came on the
show he still had his beard from The
Good Wife so I think the reason they
kept negan beard was just to avoid like
any contractual problems with The Good
Wife or anything like that but they
ended up writing it into the episode
remember when negan came to the save
zone to take all their stuff he was
looking at the tape of Rick with like
the full-on wild man Grizzly Adams beard
and was like you're not this guy anymore
look how badass you used to be so beard
equals badass they wanted negan to feel
like a badass in the first part of this
season now beardless rick is starting to
become bearded crazy Rick again but
there's a couple of things that have to
happen before he gets set up and a lot
of it has to do with this carleeee arc
from the last episode like just imagine
how much Rick would freak out if he
thought that negan was hurting Carl
negan knows he needs to uphold the
balance that's why he's taking Carl back
Carl knows this so he kind of threw it
in his face in the episode you're not
gonna kill me you can't kill me so
negan's a little pissed off about that
so he's probably gonna try and have some
fun messing with Rick's head when he
takes Carl back but there's still a lot
of road to travel before they can end
negan's rule and a really important part
of that is getting help from within the
Savior's which it seems like Daryl is
getting right now as he's escaping a lot
of you are wondering if maybe that's
Jesus that wrote him the note or if it
was sherry or if it was Dwight I think
all three of those people definitely
want to get rid of negan but the most
important ones are do I
and sherry once they start helping the
survivors out and they can really do
some good
Jesus is badass so it seems like he's
still on his mission to find out what's
going on with Daryl maybe he'll help him
escape a lot of you are wondering if
maybe he tailed back with negan and Carl
I'd be surprised if he's in the back of
that truck
I think the whole point of that Daryl's
scene at the end was the idea that
Daryl's getting out but he's gonna need
some help so it just would make sense
that Jesus would be there to help him
get the rest of the way after Dwight and
sherry help him out but right now it
just seems like Shari is more into the
idea of getting rid of negan than Dwight
is you think all those times negan
smiles at him when Sharri standing
nearby
we just set Dwight off so he seems like
a powder keg that's waiting to explode
but he just hasn't hit that tipping
point yet so hopefully they'll address
that in the final episode but if you're
reading along I still think that there
in volume 18 right now I don't think
they're gonna blow past that too quickly
but we'll probably move into volume 19
comic book story in the back half of the
season it just depends on how much comic
book stuff they do in this midseason
finale and they've been following the
comic pretty closely but we just did
issue 105 and there's a couple more
issues in volume 18 so it just depends
on how much comic book story they blow
through sometimes they do a little bit
sometimes they do a whole bunch at the
same time but the other big thing here
the kingdom acting against the Savior's
so it sounds like they're really down
with the idea like they want to get rid
of them too but there's just too many
people so we have to have that moment
when Jesus Hilltop the kingdom the
SafeZone and whoever it is that Rick and
err and run into come together and say
we're gonna work together to do this
with the help of Dwight and sherry from
the inside so let me know in the
comments what do you think is going to
be happening towards the end of this
episode next big thing killing off
characters midseason finales are always
big events for killing off characters so
which of the SafeZone people do you
think is gonna eat it spencer is on the
chopping block but it also sounds like
Olivia might eat it too but like I'm
gonna play this clip with Olivia here
that'll add some context so here watch
this and then I'll explain
[Music]
here's this damn lemonade her had some
in my kitchen
go home let me take over no I'm fine I
told Rick I would watch Judith I'm gonna
do that you should go we're about to sit
so olivia is taking her job watching
Judith super seriously I told Rick I'd
watch her so it's almost like she would
throw herself on a grenade to save
Judith
so maybe negan does something really
terrible that threatens Judith's life
and it causes Olivia to do something
that leads to her death so you get like
your big character death but she dies
doing something really noble but I'm
just really really hoping that Spencer
eats it too
because it seems like he has completely
lost his mind but I know we have all the
rosita stuff like she's staring at that
bullet so it sounds like somebody's
gonna make a play for a negan that's
probably gonna be part of the big climax
of the episodes like somebody making an
attempt on negan's life that causes
negan to retaliate there's a lot of
story to get through but the episode is
90 minutes so everybody just let me know
what you're hoping that they include
because under there been a couple of
slow episodes this season they always
try to build towards big payoffs in the
finales and the premieres so it just
sounds like they've got something really
big planned I know it's been a while
since we've seen Carol Terminator but I
feel like this coming together to end
negan's reign will bring her out of her
self-imposed exile she's in that house
so she's been helping the Kingdom people
but you see how this season they've kind
of split the survivors up some of them
stayed at the safe zone you have Carolyn
Morgan at the kingdom then you have
Sasha and Maggie at Hilltop you have
Daryl with the Savior's it just made it
easier for them to tell this broader
story by just splitting the group up
which I think a lot of people were kind
of pissed about because you always wind
up with like the really slow episodes
with like the B and C
les characters when you really want to
be following the main action so here's
my other big question what do you think
about the fact that they're telling all
these different story lines splitting
the group up do you want them to all
come back together sooner rather than
later because it feels like that's what
the back half of the season is all about
but I think you know the people that
have gone to different communities will
stay put for the time being but what's
gonna happen later tonight is there's a
new Transformers trailer I'll post a
video for that so that should be up in
the next couple of hours while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the Walking Dead episode video and
you can click here for my Westworld
finale video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight